bonsoir avoue claude blanche maison
alors on attend donc avec impatience
demain ce tête à tête en 30 ans tony
blinken et son homologue français jean
yves le drian qui on se souvient avait
eu des mots quand mamas assez dur après
cette affaire des sous-marins il avait
qu'il avait qualifié de coup dans le dos
de trahison clairement est ce que les
choses vont s'arranger en tôle et big n
est là en mission de déminage puisqu'il
y aura un entretien entre joe biden et
emmanuel macron qui fait quelques
semaines en marge du g20 qui se tient en
italie et puis il est là aussi en
mission de séduction puisque à paris
monsieur blinken passe pour être le
français de l'équipe de joe balden comme
il était le français de l'équipe obama
il a pris du galon depuis en effet il a
été élevé en france il a un bac français
mais c'est pas parce qu'il parle
français qui pensent français est en
réalité il est l'incarnation du hamel 15
bak de joe biden est évidemment il
défend des positions assez dur alors le
l'apparence et l' enveloppe et est
avenante mais le contenu reste le même
le même qu'auparavant je pense que
effectivement l'entretien risque d'être
assez serré d'autant plus qu'il ya des
thèmes qui n'ont pas encore été évoquée
par exemple la prolifération fournir des
sous marins à propulsion nucléaire à
l'australie c'est très bien bon d'abord
l'australie les aura que dans 20 ans ça
c'est le problème de l'australie c'est
si ça lui fait plaisir tant mieux mais
surtout évident beaucoup d'autres pays
de la zone voudrait des pays d des sous
marins à propulsion nucléaire et
probablement finiront par les obtenir on
apprend aujourd'hui par un journal
britannique que le brésil est en train
de fabriquer des sous marins à
propulsion nucléaire c'est donc un
problème de prolifération
parce que le combustible enrichi de
façon importante ce qui permet de
s'approcher du seuil de la deûle à delà
de la construction de la bombe atomique
donc c'est un problème tout à fait
sérieux on va on va y venir justement
mais est-ce qu'il arrive les valides
anthony blinken
et oui il arrive avec
différents sujets sur lesquels en effet
il va discuter avec ses interlocuteurs
français il est aussi voir le conseiller
diplomatique du président de la
république et il ya évidemment des
sujets sur lequel on nous sommes très
proches par exemple la lutte contre le
terrorisme dans le sahel où là les
positions américaines les français sont
très proches les américains fournissent
un soutien logistique
un soutien de transport et un soutien de
renseignement qui est très important les
drones américains fournissent énormément
de renseignement et dans le fonds compte
sur la france pour contenir ces poussées
terroristes dans le sahel donc là il ya
identité d'objectifs et les choses se
passeront probablement de façon très
opérationnelle et se passeront bien par
contre sur les autres sujets ça va être
beaucoup plus difficile alors justement
derrière la sphère de des sous-marins
évidemment il ya l'enjeu de la paix de
la sécurisation de cette zone indo
pacifique où les influences américaines
comment ça a pesé lourd justement la
france aussi elle a des intérêts avec la
nouvelle calédonie dans cette région du
monde est ce qu'il ya des points de
convergence entre la france et les états
unis oui surtout y'a pas que la nouvelle
calédonie pour laquelle d'ailleurs il y
aura un référendum si tout va bien le 12
décembre ça dépend un peu du coc vide ce
référendum on ne sait pas encore trop
sur quoi il va déboucher mais il ya
évidemment d'autres territoires français
la polynésie française qui joue un rôle
important wallis et futuna et puis il ya
aussi tous les territoires de l'océan
indien qui concilie paillote notamment
qui consignes et bien entendu la réunion
qui constitue tout un chapelet indo
pacifique qui sont des territoires
français avec autour de chaque
territoire les 200 milles marins que de
zones économiques exclusives que que
donne le traité sur le droit de la mer
par conséquent la france a des
responsabilités considérables avec le
deuxième domaine maritime du monde après
celui des etats unis je pense que les
états unis sont sensibles à ce sujet
alors on entend dire parfois que
peut-être des agences tra lien aux
agents américains auraient une action
négative par exemple pour le référendum
en nouvelle calédonie on verra bien le
haut-commissariat français sur place et
naturellement parfaitement au courant
des activités des uns et des autres et
on verra bien ce qui se passe je pense
que les deux ministres vont en parler
alors autre enjeu important les luttes
d'influencés aussi face à la chine on
sait que pyongyang un allié de la chine
effectué des essais de missiles depuis
plusieurs semaines maintenant les états
unis qui mène une stratégie visant à
contrer cette influence chinoise dans
cette zone comment la france et plus
largement l'europe se positionne par
rapport à ces surcoûts viande je pense
que tout le monde comprend que c'est la
chine qui détient la clé de l'évolution
de la corée du nord la chine qui est
d'ailleurs un peu coincé parce que la
chine d'une part donne des conseils à
kim jong hoon et à sa soeur qui ne les
suivent pas qu'ils continuent à faire
des expériences qui continuent à
franchir les lignes rouges et ceci
embarrasse la chine parce que la chine
ne veut pas que le régime de la corée du
nord disparaissent d'un seul coup elle
souhaiterait qu'il évolue un peu à la
vietnamienne en acceptant l'économie de
marché tout en gardant un régime
communiste et ils ne veulent pas par
conséquent on a là une situation de
blocage absolu et on a bien vu les
tentatives un petit peu un petit peu
bizarre de monsieur trump l'on échoué et
là je pense que il ya un sujet
extrêmement sérieux à évoquer car la
corée du nord veut considérer la bombe
nucléaire la bombe atomique comme la
garantie de sa survie alors par ailleurs
pour la deuxième question continue dans
la même qu'ici on en réalité porte sur
l'attitude européenne et française vis à
vis de la chine est bien l'attitude
française et européenne vis-à-vis gilles
d'achille et que nous ne voulons pas
faire la guerre à la chine n'y a pas de
raison de monter une croisade anti
chinoises simplement il faut très
attentifs en effet à l'influencé
chinoise qui parfois prend des chemins
détournés notamment contrôler les
investissements dans les secteurs
stratégiques il n'y a aucune raison de
se prêter à ces investissements là et
faire attention également aux
conséquences de ce qu'elle appelle les
routes de la soie c'est à dire le prise
de contrôle de porc ou de territoires
autour de l'inde et autour de nos
territoires notamment dans le pacifique
sud alors dossier à la défense
européenne l'engagement des pays
européens europe ainsi au sein de l'otan
alors ça c'est très sain pour les
américains le renforcement du pilier
européen
c'est un l'augmentation du pourcentage
du pnb consacré aux dépenses militaires
2 % au moins 2% la france y est à peu
près l'allemagne en est loin et il faut
que tous les pays atteigne ce seuil et
puis le la deuxième demande américaine
qui est formulée de façon plus implicite
c'est acheter des armes et des systèmes
d'armes américains voilà pour le reste
on peut discuter mais ce sont ces cela
les deux points-clés de manière concrète
que sur lequel les américains veulent
voir les européens s'engager en réalité
pour le reste effectivement il ne
souhaite pas qu'ils aient l'autonomie
stratégique européenne il ne la
conçoivent que enchâssé dans l'otan sous
la direction d'un état major américain
voilà donc à suivre demain donc avec
cette rencontre entre anthony blinken le
secrétaire d'état américain et son
homologue français jean yves le drian
merci à vous jean claude blanchemaison
pour cet éclairage rappelle que vous
êtes expert en relations internationales